government screws up just about
everything it touches
okay it's incredibly ineffective it's a
you know we hear about the 900
toilet seats and the 700 hammers and all
you know everything they do is very very
inefficient
we talked about it yesterday the
department of education billions and
billions of dollars is spent on the
department of education
this department did not exist when i was
in kindergarten there was no such thing
as the department of education at the
federal level and yet we still got
educated arguably better our test scores
were actually better in those days than
they are now
so they've accomplished nothing you get
the war on poverty they've spent
trillions of dollars trying to solve the
poverty problem and yet there are more
people below the poverty line than there
were when they started to try to
help people that were in poverty listen
the solution is different the solution
is not
hey we're going to give you stuff and
we're going to take from people who have
it and give to people that don't have it
to try to equalize things
and to try to equalize outcomes the
answer is people understanding what the
real message is if you
we all want to solve the problem i don't
want any children to be hungry i mean
you know i'm not i'm not
there's no lack of compassion or empathy
on my part i just think the answer is to
show them how to
you know teach a man to fish rather than
give him a fish you know he for a
lifetime
um you've heard that saying and and so i
think it's really important that people
get the right message because nobody
cares about you except you
if you think that someone else is going
to make your life better if you put your
hope
on if you think that your life is going
to get better or your only hope for a
better life is something the
government's gonna do for you
like i heard last week oh help is on the
way help
is on the way we're here from the
government and we're here to help are
you frickin kidding me
i mean really seriously if that's what
you're hoping that's gonna make your
life better you are gonna be miserable
the rest of your life waiting for
government to help you
i mean it's just not the answer and so
government's just gotten way way too big
and now they have to figure out a way to
fund it we can't we can't raise enough
money in taxes
they can't if they took a hundred
percent of the income of
billionaires and the billionaires didn't
change their behavior and leave the
country and go somewhere else they just
decided to pay it
bend over and just take it it still
wouldn't pay for all the crap they want
to pay for so we just keep printing
money
which is going to lead to inflation and
it inevitably has to because the the
value
of our dollar is going to go to nothing
this just
sort of proves why people are absolutely
in love with ronald reagan because the
game changed when he showed up in 1980
but his stuff
his his programs and his policies worked
he was correct
well did trickle-down economics actually
work absolutely
yes it did did wealth did the wealth gap
go up yes but
the bottom got lifted so the question is
if you
let's say you're poor and you're making
no money and i could double your income
okay but i'm going to triple the income
of elon musk
so i'm going to double your income but
i'm going to triple elon musk's income
thereby
raising the wealth gap the income
inequality is going to be greater than
it was
would you you're the person that's
making 40 grand and now you can make 80.
would you vote for that or you say no
that's bad because because
that's going to make elon musk even
richer
well i'm not a hater so i mean if it's
going to increase my income i'm not
going to get mad at the person so what's
the problem is the problem that elon
musk makes too much or the problem that
the poor make too little
yeah i i i got to tell you man this is
uh
this is a topic i've never been this
excited about
investing yeah i can see it i could see
it you got you have no idea how excited
i am to take a deep dive into this topic
i'm excited to learn from our laughter
is your guy we got to get out in the
room well no no i've had laffer before
we've looked at him and i i'm the weird
guy that enjoys interviewing people and
talking about flipping taxes i actually
like
talking about taxes and let's talk about
that
but not that you're not a cpa i may have
been an economist but to me it's a guy
idea that they introduced me and saying
today my guest is an entrepreneur a
content creator and author and an
economist
thank you and he's a he's an avid card
collector i'm like
an economist first time in my life i've
been called an economist i'm like okay i
mean if i
you know you didn't correct them you're
right the focus should be
on driving toward educating the people
who make policy
yeah toward what actually works not what
sounds good yeah not what sounds fair
like what actually works but i tell you
one thing here
like i i agree if a war happens
and [ __ ] hits the fan i do agree we
gotta we gotta chip into the country
fair enough i do agree if something
happens i'm not assuming the war is
like that makes sense like let me want
to set up a war just think about
let me tell you how i process that if
you're running a company
and all of a sudden the company goes
through a catastrophic issue that you're
facing say technology say something
happens
but you know you can recover from you
got to sit there and say guys you own
shares in the company you want shares in
the company i want shares in the company
let me tell you what i'm doing
here's what i'm doing my salary quarter
million dollars i'm bringing it to xero
for the next 12 months
okay i can afford that i think you can
afford that as well
i think you can afford that as well i'm
not telling you to do it all i'm telling
you is why don't we come together
and then you say honestly i'll go for 12
months on zero great i am as well i'm
all in because i think we can build this
thing together fedex you know the story
of fedex
yes then you go to your employees and
they say hey guys guess what here's what
we're doing
next 12 months i'm showing you my salary
i'm going to zero
and so is byron so is adam here's what
we're asking from you guys
we are asking you to take a 25 pick up
the next 12 months here's why
if you don't take it we totally
understand we're going to do our best to
try to pay you
but we may be cornered to having to let
go half of our staff we don't want to do
that if you stay patiently with us we're
willing to give you some warrants
whatever
to be able to get a long-term thing
going right i understand
if a catastrophic event like that takes
place i fully get it that we have to
kind of chip in and help out i fully
understand it
what happened the last 12 months does
that qualify as that
for covid where we printed 5 trillion
dollars 40
of all the money ever printed does it
qualify for us to go into that direction
we keep printing and all this stuff
see then the challenge for me becomes
the following here's where i have a
problem with byron and i need your help
as a therapist
here's what my prom becomes my problem
with with it is the following
um if we're doing business together i
trust you
i actually really trust you and this is
not a script i trust you as a human
being a lot if you were you and i were
in the business together
you took care of accounting i wouldn't
i'd be like dude i know what you're
going to be doing i don't i trust you
i trust this kind of business together
right he's going to be a guy that's
we're going to be all in
and your motive is going to be to help
use every penny in the pro
best possible way to help us stay afloat
so three years from now we're going to
be big right or we'll come back and hey
say guys we build the company we're
doing good now same with you
i don't trust who's managing the money
today of the tax taxes that we're paying
them i just don't trust
could you i mean that's that's my
problem the problem for me with taxes
isn't i don't mind paying it i went to
boca dear
meisner the other day and when you want
to have a cup of coffee you got to pay
to say 11.79 your parking spot and you
pay this machine it takes you three
minutes to freaking do it it's really
slow
you get the ticket you go there and you
leave right takes about three minutes to
do it
i made a video and i said here's how
taxes ought to be
pay taxes for things you use that
parking space i have no problem paying
taxes for that because i'm about to use
it well that's the average person
ask them to look even just someone who
makes 60 60 grand look what they pay it
to the federal government
and you say okay well i know i'm pa what
about school well schools aren't had
nothing to do with your federal taxes
what about your fire department that's
not that's not federal taxes your police
department's not federal taxes federal
taxes go for the military they go for
roads and bridges
they they're you know keeping a stable
currency but i mean think about what you
pay
and think about what you get and the
average person looks and says this is a
rip-off
it's a rip-off because the government
doesn't spend money efficiently
they're not good managers of money the
government i mean
john stossel did a really nice piece on
this public bathroom do you ever see it
mm-hmm
he's in his stostel's obese by the way
yeah yeah yeah he's a beast put him on
the list
put him on the list listen it'll be
great to get out of the room
um they showed this little small
bathroom it was like a box
you know made out of bricks and there
was a men's and women's bathroom in this
public park and they were interviewing
people stossel was interviewing people
what did it cost to build this do you
think
the first guest says i don't know ten
thousand dollars and obviously didn't
know
somebody said seventy thousand hundred
and twenty thousand the guesses were you
know about what it would be you know
thinking my house cost my house is three
times this size
and that costs this much so maybe a
third of that or half that
costs two million dollars to build this
bathroom and that's the way government
works
it's just the way it is is that where
you're going with your point pet yeah
kind of i think
actually that bathroom analogy is that
yeah i don't trust where the money's
being spent i remember when we were in
the army they would show the statements
of what it cost what we paid for
simple bolt like wait is this seriously
how much we're paying for is that that's
how much military price i said dude
that's
i go down the street i pay i pay 30
cents for that how much are we paying
five dollars
why why are we paying five dollars
there's no accountability
there is no account this is sort of the
biggest problem i mean i totally agree
but this is also sort of the biggest
problem with defense spending is that we
i mean you were in the military you get
it when you have the amount you have
spending on defenses
i don't disagree either there i i again
going back to it i
don't trust how that money is being used
because there's no accountability to
know
right how they're using that money so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye